at the heart of a snowblower are
rotating blades called augers the left
and right augur spiral in opposite
directions in order to move snow toward
the middle there a fan called an
impeller swallows the snow and blows it
out a chute each author starts out as a
partially formed steel disc just under
an eighth of an inch thick
a press applies about 200 tons of
pressure to form the augers final shape
meanwhile robots are welding together
the steel housing that will eventually
case the augers it takes the robots just
55 seconds to weld a housing
next the housings undergo an
electrostatic paint process powder paint
laced with a positive electrical charge
is drawn to the housings which are
negatively charged then the housing
spend 15 minutes in an oven which bakes
on the paint in another part of the
factory workers are assembling the snow
blowers gas-powered engine and
transmission
after bolting on the impeller they
attached a large steel axle to the
transmission driven sprocket then they
slide the now painted auger and hub
units onto the axle
now it's time to bolt the auger assembly
into the snow blower housing the
impeller slides into a cup that's
centered at the back of the housing then
they screw the housing to the
transmission frame the last component is
the snowblowers handle there's a lever
for selecting different speeds and
clutch levers that can be locked down to
direct the wheels and augers there's
also a headlight so that you'll be
visible to oncoming cars while clearing
snow at night there's also a lever that
lets you choose the direction to blow
the snow